creative keyboard's goal is to to help
people communicate better right most of
our social lives today there's on social
text apps on our phone and the thing is
not everybody is as good as in
communicating via text as everybody else
right some people are very good uh
person to person communicating like face
to face but when they're giving texts
given texting on a chat app it's not
easy for them and they can't express
themselves
so that's what that's the problem we're
going to sell we're trying to solve
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're going to be talking to noi
Shulman all about Consulting with
artificial intelligence the integration
of artificial intelligence into
Enterprise and how we can leverage Ai
and NLP solutions for different
mechanisms today he is running a new
company which we'll talk about as well
make noise a data scientist and AI
algorithm researcher adapt in developing
tailored AI solutions for companies
noise specializes in helping companies
integrate deep learning algorithms into
existing products
talking from a one of the best areas in
the world of Ho Chi thank you very much
for being here no you've been working on
some really really fun things I have to
say you know working a lot with with
companies and integrating artificial
intelligence into their into their
Cycles into their technology stack and
something that I'm that I'm deeply
curious about because it's something
that is so relevant in our life today as
we have so much research taking place
and into into these new models that are
coming out some of them are are more
generalized some of them are more
fine-tuned and I'm curious to hear your
perspective on the integration of these
Technologies either either from research
lead in-house or taken as a black box
and then also transitioning to talking
about yeah the new company that you're
working on that is very NLP centered so
thank you again for being here and I'd
love to hear a little bit about your own
background sort of how what is your
background with technology how did you
get into the artificial intelligence
space
uh uh I'm an electrical engineer I
studied as a technical
so I finished school about five years
ago at University and I just fell in
love with AI during school I just took
this course on computer vision because
somebody told me it was cool and I just
fell in love with it immediately and I
said this is what I want to do
and then I quit my the other job that I
had in chip design and I said I'm gonna
find a job or I get to do deep learning
and it wasn't that easy because back
then every company I called was like
we're accepting only PhD and we're doing
that and I I just didn't let go until I
found this company who gave me a chance
and this was a
very small company and what we were
doing is the giving services to
different Enterprises and also different
startups they want to develop their
machine learning or deep learning
capabilities but don't know how to do
that
so that's what I did for about two years
and then I just uh I moved out of that
and just starting doing the same thing
on my own so me and my brother started
in business he's more of a hardware guy
I would do algorithms and so we also did
a lot of projects that are really end to
end but you have Caldwell take actually
the signals and also do the algorithms
that uh we we were giving a whole
solution enough for the past about six
months I've been doing something called
creative keyboard that we're going to
talk about later amazing and so tell me
a little bit about your store with say a
little bit about your work you know
what's your brother working with
companies I'd love to understand a
little bit better sort of the process of
what you've learned about the
integration of these AI systems within
organizations what what you know what
what types of
of the I guess relationships do you have
when you're when you're coming in
outside and helping them do this either
you know do you develop it do you mainly
consult with them on what technologies
to use how does it actually work
so it really changes sometimes we were
hard to do Consulting and sometimes we
did the whole integration and
implementation and everything
and that
more into that the the world has kind of
changed I think uh introduction of gpt3
style models like very large language
models kind of change the world but not
that much because they're not practical
in every use case so even though I
haven't been doing this for a long time
like people say oh I've been doing this
for 20 years I'm only about five years
in this business the things change five
years ago we didn't even have three
solutions five years ago we didn't even
have friends so your your before even
you know the main big the big hype that
we've had
oh yeah so we think about now about the
introduction of gpt3 as a very
transformative technology but before
that came built and Bert was really
exciting because
because it was the first time that
people made a general language model
that we can fine tune uh trade on a lot
of data and fine tune on a different
task I guess it's probably not the first
time but it was a model that was very
widely adopted but still when we were
using birth we needed a lot of data from
the company or the Enterprise that is
specific to their tasks which is kind of
different today with a very large large
language models so what we would do is
come to some organization
talk to them about the task and
understand if they can actually have the
data because usually uh not usually I
think 99 of the time and this world and
it was true since even before birth that
the models of Open Source you don't
really invent any algorithms today like
some people do but most people or the
world is going towards data driven so
it's a lot more important to have the
right data and understand what does that
mean because that's not an easy task as
well so have me no an organization has
and and tell me what you know you're
mentioning the importance of data in
fine tuning but let's let's talk to me a
little bit more about why they
generalized approach of gpd3 Jurassic
Megazord Palm Lambda all these large
language models that these huge
companies are building why are they not
and one size fits-all solution to these
NLP types of questions that that
companies have why is that not enough
okay that that's a good question and it
might be enough okay for some tests
these modelers are definitely enough and
there are two types of tests I would
divide the answer that these miners are
are not a good match okay the first one
is is it a lot easier to understand it's
about money these models are expensive
to run so if you run your model A lot of
times and you need a lot of answers and
you get little value
out of every answer they it might not be
a good fit for you because it's just not
expensive so it's not it's sorry it's
very expensive so it's not it's just not
scalable you want something cheaper so
you want a smaller model than dp3 who's
using it is very expensive because it's
a lot of processing power okay so this
is one uh one reason why not use this
huge models and the other uh the other
is that it's just they don't really
always Supply the
the right answers so maybe you can use
gpt3 and also fine tune it on some of
your own data to make it understand
better your use case but in the end when
you're using this very huge models you
need to give them some sort of prompt so
if this is a very easy task you can just
use the prompt to tell the model what
you want but if it's uh and it has it a
little more complicated many times
you'll be a lot better fine-tuning the
model so if you fight you in this huge
Megazord
that's good and it will get you the best
results but you usually can use not a
lot of examples even tens or hundreds of
examples to find you a smaller model
maybe 10 times smaller than gpt3 and get
better results than a non-fine-tuned
gpt3
I mean that makes sense
in regards to to the data for fine
tuning what does that look like what is
fine-tuning what does that require from
a company who come and says we want to
be special we want to specialize in a
specific context
and they're thinking okay how do I make
sense of fine-tuning generalized
approaches what what do they do at that
point
literally tangibly Okay so
so it it's definitely very different
between different companies so let's uh
try and think of an example
so let's say there is a company and I'm
sure there is a company that does uh
that takes the doctor's notes from uh
patient meetings
and this doctor who writes the things in
his uh free language okay yes free
language the patient is feeling that and
that right I saw this in this and they
want to take an NLP model to make this
into some kind of brackets for insurance
claims okay so another uh software can
process it later so data data for that
can look like the actual doctor's notes
and then the tabular data that we want
to get out of there so where's the
problem sometimes the com a company
can't Supply that data because maybe
it's confidential maybe they just they
just didn't store it
okay so that's how data looks like and
it presents many challenges to different
uh
to the companies because let's say a
company they think they're smart Okay
first question I used to ask the company
when I'm meeting them or tell me about
your data okay and this company oh no
problem we thought about that okay and
then we have to die to dive deeper so if
we go into that same question let's say
they thought about that and they have
this one Clinic where the patient said
they sign some wavelet and you can store
all the data from that plane okay but
that clinic might be in some sort of
neighborhood where they only have uh
let's say uh
old people and it doesn't really reflect
in a different neighborhood where maybe
they have a lot of immigrants or maybe
they have a lot of young children
so sometimes the company collects data
but the data isn't diverse and it
doesn't really reflect the real world
problem that they want to stay I'll say
so later so that's also very crucial
make sure the data fit uh
your test
and that's it usually the data is the
challenge it's not easy
let's say we have the data right so
let's say I have you know structured
unstructured data whatever according to
the problem that I want to solve I'm a
clinic with a specific use case that I
have
now at this point do I need to have some
in-house researchers that are doing this
do I leverage generally I'll Outsource
platforms how do I then actually take
this data in fine tune it to a model
that fits my use case what what type of
what type of resources do I then need as
an organization do I need to deploy in
order to actually make this into a
working NLP model for me
okay
so you will need somebody that knows how
to to do this preferably in-house and
not the outsourced facility things are
very Dynamic and you wanna you want
somebody that will uh go with the model
and know how to improve it but the
researchers resources that you need to
do this are a lot uh smaller than it
used to be because you used to really
need a theme data scientists and
algorithm researchers and do everything
and now since open source platforms open
such as the hugging phase where you have
all the models and you can even train
online you can do almost everything as a
one-man show I think data cleaning it
cleaning it training a model and doing
everything and then integrating it uh
just like 1000 person can do this and uh
it's it's not very difficult today like
the actual technical part of it
taking the data putting it in some sort
of format uploading it
to let's say hanging face if you it's
just a very popular open source platform
and training the model the I think where
the expertise come in is
analyzing the results
you can train the model but making sure
it's good making sure you don't have
biases which is our can be crucial in
some companies
and uh
then building some sort of feedback loop
where you can understand where your
model is not doing good enough and
improve it I think these are the crucial
jobs of algorithm uh developers today
not actually writing the algorithm as it
used to be but building some sort of
feedback loop to analyze the model
get more data and improve it
is the most important thing an
organization needs to know and also an
algorithm developer yes I'm sorry no no
it's fine if we're looking a little bit
ahead and we're and you're mentioning
that there's shifts right before we
needed some significant resources in
in-house and researchers and data
scientists we needed a team now we need
a person
you know we we had to create everything
from scratch now we have these open
source models that we can leverage and
work off of and and you're mentioning
another Trend that the the a big part of
the job is turning from a focus of
building the model and training it to a
process of evaluating it and improving
on it fine-tuning on it you know it's
iterations
where are we headed so you know the
we're we're moving very very fast we're
looking at what AI 21 Labs is doing in
its effort to commoditize these large
language models and and and a lot of
developer friendly platforms like
hugging face that are pushing the
boundaries if we're looking towards
three years down the line what what are
we imagining or what really you
speculate will be the process that an
organization that is not AI focused from
the get-go what will they need to do in
order to create a tailored NLP solution
for their own use case assuming that the
gpd4 of the world will not be a will not
be a black box ready for them to use
so just like I said before it's all
about data okay first of all I don't
believe so I I now return to the data in
a second I don't believe that uh
algorithm developers are not going to be
needed it's just like we had in software
where people used to write and see and
this uh very hard languages and today we
have very easy to use uh libraries and
languages such as python they just do
abstraction for all the things that
people had to write by themselves I feel
it's the same thing okay you had to do
the bits and bytes uh you used to do
that in algorithms and now you're doing
one level above that you but you still
have to decide which algorithm you're
using which model fits the task better
best and all sorts of things now to
answer your question and return to the
data it's all about the data so
companies even though they're not AI
focused from the get-go they always need
to be data driven like you need to save
as much data as you can there's some
limitations obviously the regulations
and all that sort of stuff but if you
have a lot of data preferably if you can
tag it in some way and organize it then
you will be able to implement AI
Solutions fairly easily to your
organization and what I started saying
before is about feedback loops once you
have that uh professional algorithm
developer in your organization one of
his main tasks will be to develop a
feedback loop where you implement the
actual AI in the product get feedback
understand when it's working and not
working and then get more data to
improve it and that's not an easy task
it's not an easy task to know when the
model is not doing that well especially
if it's in scale because you need people
to actually look or evaluate it in some
way it is not easy and
and then getting more data to train the
model again also not easy where do you
come up with unit new data let's say
this organization has been collecting
some sort of user data for three years
so now you understand you have
this whole subset of the data that
doesn't exist that you want to create
it's not easy to create it to create
something that actually is Meaningful
and will improve the model
interesting so I think it's a very
holistic approach so you need to think
of the customer the data the algorithm
they're all working together towards
making better models
Now sort of to wrap up the conversation
on on companies leveraging NLP for their
own use cases before we transition to to
this to your new company
if we're looking at our sort of a
timeline strategic you know today most
organizations still do not employ NLP as
a as a real resource of the organization
some of them are you know are using some
tools but it's not it's it's not yet
appearing in our in our daily lives and
and and I think we can both agree that
NLP is going to transform fundamentally
a lot of the way that organizations
leverage communication text internally
externally
you know when do you expect we will have
some significant increase in usage in in
organizations that are you know the long
tail of small businesses that are able
to harness NLP how far away are we is
this you know months is this years what
and what do you think needs to happen
for us to actually get there
it's a great question uh
I think there are different types of
organizations right so the innovators
will innovate
organizations and companies that are
used to adopting new technologies will
adopt them just like let's say 30 years
ago you had restaurants uh all the
restaurants were taking the the bills
and the orders by hand and and now you
have everybody has tablets right but
there are still restaurants that are
still doing the same thing and writing
these notes by hand sure so these
companies that are not willing to
innovate will not innovate that's we
have to remember that right
and then which companies will uh will
adopt the NLP
I I believe I I believe many companies
it will happen I think not in the next
month but let's say two three five years
we will see a lot more solutions
but it's also we need to remember that
this is a means to an end by the company
doesn't have to have an LLP it has to
solve some sort of problem for this
company
and we can think of different problems
that uh this technology solves but uh
that's not the goal right you know
adopting NLP to companies I believe a
lot of uh small businesses there's some
a lot of startups will build products
for small medium-sized businesses that
will make adopting this technology
varies
so so we will see a variety of solutions
that are coming out that that are you
know realize okay these are some general
um General use cases that companies need
to leverage in regards to NLP and we
already see some of these companies
coming up like copy AI anywhere that are
leveraging sort of the copywriting
aspect of NLP and then they're allowing
organizations to use it as a service not
everything has to be in-house I'm sure
we can extrapolate on many more but no
you're taking a more consumer approach
to NLP tell me about what you've been
working on the last six months
so I've been working on Creative
keyboard uh creative keyboard's goal is
to it's not to use these models but it's
using this models to help people
communicate better right most of our
social lives today is on social text
apps on our phone right that is that how
you talk most of your friends I guess
most of the time WhatsApp Snapchat
Facebook messenger that's just how we
live right now and you and I are
probably the same age with people 10 or
20 years younger than us are doing that
even more and I believe that's not going
that's not really going to change uh
it's just going to grow and the thing is
not everybody is as good as in
communicating via text as everybody else
right some people are very good uh
person to person communicating like face
to face but when they're giving text
given texting on a chat app it's not
easy for them and they can't express
themselves
so that's what that's the problem we're
going to sell we're trying to solve okay
we want to help people communicate
better
through text on their on their phone and
we're doing this by giving them
suggestions okay so we're actually a
smartphone keyboard
that uses Ai and uh very large language
models to give you suggestions on what
to say so it can be something to start
off a conversation it can be a reply
something that somebody asked you and
can be a compliment we have a few
different features and uh we're just
starting out and we're trying to figure
out what's the best UI to make this
possible how to make the user actually
want to use this and uh we're actually
all about users so I talked to
there are users of the the app it's like
it on the Google Play Store you can
download it playing around and I talk
with the users every day to understand
how to make this better what are the use
cases that are actually uh being used
and uh that's about it that's creative
keyboard what do you think is the most
popularly used for Creative keyboard
let me listen for you for me and well I
and and then I have a few questions
about creative people it's not a popular
use for you
what do you think people use it for not
what would you use it for
it's a great question
the great question was popular is afraid
of keyboard
um so where do people really want to
excel at communicating via text and it's
crucial for them
they really want to be good at
for me it's uh for me would be automatic
responding to things that I would
respond anyways you know for me it's you
know the very simple yes no or or you
know responses that that I that I have
to be online in real time constantly on
my phone and respond to people and if I
have a way of of personalizing that that
mechanism for me but I think that speaks
also to a larger question I had before
of is this more of a generalized
approach or a personalized approach in
regards to now the NLP space how much of
the creative keyboard is me versus how
much of it is a is a generalized
communication standard that you learn
across a variety of people
you just ask the best question it's a
great question so thank you for that uh
the goal is to have it very personal
right but when you just start using it
it's not personalized at all right get
some kind of a generalized uh model with
a few pictures but as soon as you start
using it you start inputting data into
the system that makes it very
personalized so the choices that you
make every time you use the keyboard it
gives you three suggestions okay yeah
every time you press on something it
learns what how you like to sound like
watch the tone watch the different
things what you use most and very
quickly it create a personalized digital
well I kind of I would say companion
that knows what are the things that you
like are saying now this is a trap that
you can also fall to because I don't
want to always suggest you the same
things because maybe in some other time
you want to talk a bit differently so I
also don't want the model to overfit
stamps out of you that you won't all the
time so I have to insert some noise and
sometimes make it a little different
so the goal is to have it very
personalized but for that you have to
use the keyboard and it has to know you
interesting now if you're looking at
autocomplete and the keyboard
suggestions that we've been having you
know for quite some time so obviously
you're coming and saying listen guys
this is not working we can do much
better than that where where did these
Auto suggestions fail I guess in your
eyes that led you to to start this
creative keyboard and I wanted to put
the special emphasis on that on the
creative work that you decided to put in
the beginning of the product name
so
it doesn't it definitely sounds like
we're doing something that's uh similar
to Auto suggestion but actually when you
use it you you realize it's uh
absolutely different what suggestions do
is uh complete you right you start
typing something and they tell you
what's the probable next word okay they
don't invent anything from nothing and
they're definitely not responsive to the
person you're talking with they don't
know what the other person wrote to you
and so how to respond what we're doing
is giving you actual suggestions let's
say uh you know I got a a new dog I just
adopted a new dog and so you want to ask
me questions about the dog but maybe you
just you're just not sure what's the
right thing to say what what do I ask
see you can write down in the keyboard
press the button and it will offer you
different suggestions different
questions about dogs
so let's say you and then you can pick
one of them let's say you don't like
these questions press again you'll get
different suggestions maybe you don't
like the phrasing of how it said it you
can press on the paraphrase button and
get a different phrasing for the same
sentence but that's something that's the
autocomplete it just they can't do they
solve a different problem right they
make your life more efficient we try to
make you communicate better by giving
you different sentences to different
suggestions to say
interesting when I get a new dog now
diving a little bit deeper into the
anulty scene I get I adopted you dog and
now a lot of my conversations are going
to be centered around that right this is
a new information that the model wasn't
trained on it doesn't understand this
yet but how do you then technologically
go and
be able to personalize sort of a
response to something that you may not
know exists yet right how do I how what
is sort of my interaction with with the
model that you're building that allows
it to then extrapolate on how Michael
will want to respond in regards to a new
Ascent that happens in Michael's life
um you you mean people ask you about
that new dog that you adopted well I
mean perhaps I I mean in my in my in my
daily communication I my communication
changes based on my life's events it
changes based on my for my Outlook
during the day some days I'm more
optimistic some days are more
pessimistic it's the more optimistic and
some days I have and some weeks I have
something that I'm really excited about
that that is sort of the center of my
conversation how does how does a model
or a creative keyboard adapt to my
changing neurons that are changing based
on experiences that that the model isn't
aware of necessarily
okay so we first need to remember that
this is not some sort of boss that talks
for you right this is a keyboard that
gives you suggestions right like when uh
when you ask the question I felt like oh
maybe let's uh boss is not talking like
me no that's not the uh that's not the
situation no they were the one questions
definitely so let's talk about replies
because I think it so somebody asked me
a question and maybe on Sunday I'm
feeling very happy and grateful for my
life so I want to give a responsive it's
that on some other day I have a bad mood
and I want to say something else right I
want to reflect that in my answer
because I don't want to give some sort
of a wrong impression so creative
keyboard is built around there when you
press the reply button you get these
Emoji emojis that uh you can pick one of
them and get their replies on the modes
of uh what you're feeling so you can
actually try to press the Emoji of what
fits you best today and you'll get a
uh reply that fits your mode okay now we
need to remember that this is also
personalized so the keyboard will learn
how you respond when you're in sort of
mood because maybe some one person wants
to share his feelings and talk about it
and you and some other person
acts differently and rather not talk
about it and just make the other people
person just know that he's not really up
for a conversation today so we need to
remember that there are different first
sets and each one can have the mood
button a little different sure sure so
that's what we're doing we obviously
can't respond to your life event without
knowing what it is but we the keyboard
has enough functionality to make you
very easily
uh teach it what's going on with you and
I think this speaks to the important
trend of the integration of NLP with
different use cases which is this idea
of what is sort of our our input into a
response from from the model right and
you're mentioning yes Michael you're not
going to be I'm not trying to replace
you with the bot I'm not I'm not
recreating Michael what I am doing
though is I'm allowing you to give to to
create some some idea of how Michael
responds and how Michael thinks and if
you're able to guide me with some very
very quick inputs into what where you're
at right now then I can guide you
towards something that will be closer to
what you would have responded and and so
I guess the the thesis here is that if I
if I give you a few quick inputs that
are easy for me you'll be able to
provide me with the more comprehensive
response that I would have responded
with and and all I need to do is I I
need to guide you with this you key
inputs right and that's really the the
the the creativeness here
yeah uh
I agreed until you said that's the
creativeness yeah okay because what I
thought you were saying is about uh
recreating a digital micro but I can
talk the same as Michael and just uh
being about efficiency right you you
pick the thing instead of actually
writing it down but that's not really
our goal because uh you don't need a
digital you because you have you you can
just type whatever you want sure I want
to help you be more creative on your
text conversations okay and so the
keyboard actually suggests things that
you might want to say but you didn't
think of at the same moment maybe
because you're not just that great at
communicating via textures I believe of
the face-to-face we talk differently so
I want to suggest things that you want
to say that will have a more meaningful
conversation or it doesn't have even to
be meaningful can be funny it can be fun
I want you to have a better interactions
using the keyboard so this button we
have it actually is to just a cheated
suggestions based on uh some subjects
that you write okay
so
uh and so sometimes I talk with my
girlfriend when I'm using the app and
she's like uh honey can you bring some
uh cheese home and then I put cheese
into the suggestions and get some funny
shitty sentences that I I tell her you
melt me like cheese and these kind of
things now she knows I'm not serious and
it's the keyboard but it makes the
conversation funny and fun and uh just
makes the interaction I think better for
both of us instead of it being just
transactional
I love that I love that so so that and
so that's the creative part that's very
very poor and and obviously we're
getting into a world of communication
and how do we you know obviously we
don't communicate as nobody communicates
as well as as we as we potentially can
and and and I love that I love that idea
I'm gonna I'm gonna play it out myself
uh it's uh and I can only imagine how in
in so many different contexts this
creative piece it helps create more
meaningful interactions it creates more
interest it creates higher engagement
with the people that we're communicating
with so so creative keyboard and this
company in general what is sort of the
vision or what is a success in in your
eyes
uh a success is what we have when we
help millions of people communicate
better
in their social interactions on mobile
and hopefully long term not I'm not sure
hopefully this will happen but I believe
the world is becoming a lot more online
if it's uh the metaverse or any kind of
digital world that we're gonna be
interacting with so hopefully we'll be a
major product that helps you communicate
better in any one of these digital
spaces it's uh starting with mobile
ending with this metaverse or whatever
it will be called that I believe will
happen in a few years fantastic okay I
really want to thank you for taking time
to just chat with me
um I I love the perspective on the
integration of these machine learning
models into business use cases the
generalist versus fine-tuned approaches
where we're at to do with NLP moving on
to sort of the consumer side of it and
the different use cases that you're now
adapting your toes in and leveraging
your experience with so I I'm personally
excited to try out creative keyboard and
myself and thank you very much for the
time and for the energy and and best of
luck with with this company and with
with everything else that you'll do hey
I really enjoy this conversation thank
you
thank you Michael I had a great time
thank you
[Music]